Hello tout le monde, c’est Marine !
Je vais participer au triathlon de Paris
en me mettant dans les conditions
d’une personne aveugle.
Je fais ça pour vous montrer que
le sport, c’est avant tout du partage,
du dépassement de soi,
que c’est pour tout le monde
et surtout, peu importe son physique.
Je vais avoir l’impression
de courir avec les bras en l’air, moi.
- Donc c’est bon, on commence
par la marche et après, on trotte.
Allez, on commence à trottiner,
un, deux, trois.
- Je vois vraiment rien et j’entends
des bruits qui sont démultipliés.
J’entends le bruit des voitures et
j’ai l’impression qu’elles sont toutes proches.
J’entends la musique derrière et
je sens beaucoup le sol aussi par terre.
Là, je sais qu’on est repassés sur du dur.
- Tout droit.
- Après, c’est différent
par rapport à des malvoyants
ou des personnes qui
ne voient pas du tout de naissance
ou qui le sont devenues
parce que là, on est arrivés
donc je sais où on est,
je sais qu’il y avait une partie d’herbe
et une partie de bitume on va dire,
donc j’essaie de me repérer.
Mais des gens qui n’ont jamais rien vu,
ils n’ont pas la notion de ça dans leur tête.
C’est, je pense, encore plus dur.
Waouh...
Ce défi, je vais le réaliser
avec un guide, Julien Hervio.
Il est actuellement guide
pour Arnaud Grandjean
qui fait partie de l’équipe
de France de paratriathlon.
- Top.
- Dans chaque épreuve, quel est
le rôle du guide dans chaque partie ?
- En natation, c’est assez simple,
c’est faire le parcours le plus court
et on est reliés par un lien qui va donner
la possibilité d’avoir des informations.
Parce que si j’ai envie d’aller à gauche,
je tire un peu plus sur le lien avec la jambe,
si j’ai envie d’aller à droite,
je viens me serrer contre toi.
Les automatismes font que
petit à petit, tu décaleras sur la droite.
- D’accord.
- Un, deux, trois.
La difficulté va être que les gens ne soient
pas au courant qu’il y a un lien entre nous deux.
Certaines personnes vont vouloir
nous doubler juste entre nous deux.
Et donc se faire arracher le lien,
ce serait vraiment… pas cool du tout.
- Là j’ai bien tourné, non ?
- Très bien, super, parfait.
- Ouais, je me suis bien sentie.
Du coup en vélo, ton rôle ?
- La difficulté dans le tandem,
c’est partir sur le tandem.
On met le pied sur la pédale,
on lève, encore, voilà, c’est bon.
Un, deux, trois, on est partis.
Il faut pédaler mais faut être très souple.
C'est comme sur une moto, il faut pas aller
contre ce que veut faire le guide.
- Par rapport aux virages, par rapport à tout ça ?
- Par rapport aux virages,
par rapport à la souplesse du pédalage.
- Et en course à pied, du coup ton rôle, c’est ?
- Il faut que le guide soit pas
beaucoup plus fort que l’athlète
mais il faut quand même
avoir la possibilité de parler,
pour informer de n’importe quel obstacle,
quand on va à gauche,
quand on va à droite,
savoir les sensations de l’athlète
malvoyant ou aveugle.
Plus la personne est handicapée visuellement,
il faut être le plus proche possible
pour qu’il y ait plus de sensations
et de communication par rapport à ce lien.
Pour cette épreuve, nous allons faire 500 mètres
de natation dans le bassin de la Villette,
enchaînés par 20 kilomètres de vélo
en passant par République
et on va terminer par
5 kilomètres de course à pied.
- À peu de choses près, la distance
réalisée sur ce triathlon de Paris,
le triathlon S par Marine, c'est quasiment
la distance des Jeux paralympiques.
Concernant les personnes déficientes visuelles,
il y a deux sous-catégories :
la catégorie des non-voyants
et la catégorie de B2-B3,
qu’on va appeler les malvoyants.
- Je commence à m'habituer.
- Merci, bonne course !
- Bon courage à vous, merci !
Pour une fois, je suis vraiment contente.
Bon, ça y est, j'ai
presque mes lunettes
complètement noires,
opaques, sur les yeux.
Julien qui est là.
Julien qui est en forme !
C'est grâce à lui
que je vais faire tout ça.
On se retrouve après.
Attention Paris...
Et c'est parti.
Allez !
- Le paratriathlon a fait son entrée
aux Jeux paralympiques sur les Jeux de 2016.
Très vite, ça a cartonné.
La particularité du paratriathlon,
c'est qu'il est géré
par, directement,
la Fédération française de triathlon.
C'est-à-dire qu'elle s'est ouverte
aux personnes handicapées.
Un sport grand public, qui dit :
"Oui, on est ouvert à tous les types de situation."
Ça roule bien derrière.
Parce que moi, clairement,
tous les déficients visuels que je croise,
ils sont en train de se mettre plus ou moins au triathlon.
On ne jure que par le paratriathlon
aujourd'hui, c'est assez rigolo.
C’est bientôt fini !
Les paratriathlètes,
ils sont là avec le bonnet vert,
avec leur guide.
Et également, eh bien, Marine Leleu.
Tiens, la selle est là.
Je mets mes chaussures et on est partis.
Hop, c'est bon, on est partis ?
On marche ou on court ?
- On peut courir si tu veux.
- Allez.
Hop, on tourne légèrement à droite.
Fortement à droite.
Voilà, monte.
C'est bon pour toi ?
Allez.
C’est parti pour 25 bornes.
Un peu de pavés pour s’amuser un peu.
Mini dos-d’âne là.
On se soulève un peu.
On reste debout sur les pédales, voilà.
T'es super souple, c'est chouette !
Allez, on envoie les watts !
Ça demande beaucoup plus
d'organisation quand on est aveugle.
Il faut trouver la personne
pour vous accompagner
ou le créneau ou l'espace,
la salle de sport ou la piscine sera un peu dispo
parce que quand il y a beaucoup de monde,
c'est pas facile.
Ou les coachs qui prendront le temps
de bien vous expliquer les exercices
parce que quand on vous montre,
vous le voyez pas.
- On est où là ?
- Quai de Valmy, de l’autre côté.
- Ok.
- On remonte. Il doit nous rester 3/4km.
- On serre à droite, j’ai pas de freins !
* Rires *
Ça sent le poulet grillé !
- Droite, gauche, la droite est faite,
on lève la patte, gauche, voilà.
Virage à gauche.
- Allez, courage !
Allez, allez, on continue !
- On revient dans la Villette.
- Allez Marine ! Allez Marine, allez, allez !
Allez Mariiiiine !
- Allez Julien !
On va descendre du vélo.
On avance encore un peu, encore un peu.
Hop, maintenant, pied gauche.
T'as la selle, c'est bon ?
On finit les pavés.
Virage à droite.
- Allez, allez, allez.
- Dans 20 mètres, on pose le vélo.
Donne-moi la main.
Hop.
C’est bon pour toi ?
- Ouais.
- Attends, hop, par là. Allez.
C'est parti ?
- Ouais.
- Hop, on redescend.
On redescend tout doucement.
Virage à droite, léger.
Allez, courage à vous.
- Merci, vous aussi surtout !
- Alleeeez !
- Super, allez, allez !
- Tu veux te faire arroser ou pas ?
On va être obligés.
Allez Marine !
- Allez Julien !
- L’eau elle est là, là ?
- L’eau à droite, ouais.
- Ok. C’est à 1 mètre, 2 mètres ?
C'est loin quand meme ?
- Euh...2 mètres 12.
- D'accord.
- Vous pouvez serrer à gauche,
un petit peu, monsieur s’il vous plaît ?
Merci beaucoup.
Ah oui, je t’ai pas dit, on a eu de l’eau.
- Non mais j'ai entendu !
Ça serait bien si
c'était comme le tandem,
qu'on aurait nos deux vitesses cumulées !
- Ouais. On aurait gagné !
- Le paratriathlon,
c'est vraiment un chemin de vie.
On peut dire que voilà, ils ont pris le dessus.
Peu importe les chronos qu'ils vont faire derrière,
ils sont capables de faire quelque chose
que la plupart des gens n'imaginent pas faire.
- Demi-tour, demi-tour, demi-tour, demi-tour,
demi-tour, demi-tour, demi-tour, demi-tour...
Hop, hop.
Alors, tu vas avoir des herbes qui vont
te frôler la jambe de temps en temps
parce qu'ils ont pas fait le ménage.
- Ooooh... Attends...
- C'est bon, c'est bon, c'est bon.
Ça y est, c'est fini.
On a passé la partie difficile.
- Allez Marine !
- Bravo, c'est super !
- Merci.
Hop, passerelle dans 20 mètres.
On commence à monter.
Ça monte léger au début,
ça s’amplifie après.
On tourne.
Allez, il y a Myriam, ça serait bien
qu’on arrive presque avec elle.
Allez Myriam, allez !
- Bravo Marine !
- Merci.
- Bravo, c'est super ce que t'as fait !
C’était un peu compliqué par moments
mais franchement, je suis très contente,
je suis très fière, de pouvoir montrer
que tout le monde peut faire du sport
et qu’on peut tous s’aider, s’entraider.
Merci beaucoup Julien
parce que c’était vraiment chouette.
- Faire du sport tout seul, c'est bien.
Après, quand on peut le partager,
c’est comme la vie, c’est comme dans un couple,
c'est mieux de vivre à deux que tout seul.
- Ça se voit pas sur moi parce que
mon handicap ne touche pas mon œil
et donc j'ai la chance,
j'arrive dans mon quotidien, si tu veux,
à faire assez bien illusion
quand j'ai tous mes repères, tu vois.
Je connais tout par cœur.
- Le fait d'être hyper proche de son guide,
le fait de créer quelque chose, moi, c'est vrai
que je l'ai directement senti avec Julien
et c'est sûr que c'est incroyable.
Et je crois qu’il faut vraiment le vivre
pour le décrire et pour le partager.
- C'est forcément une relation
un petit peu inégale, je veux dire,
parce que moi, j’y gagne beaucoup plus
encore que peut gagner Dany.
Je pense qu'effectivement,
il me permet énormément,
il me rend ce sport accessible, tout simplement.
- Une personne qui devient guide
doit être là, justement, pour partager
avec l'athlète des moments forts
et pour être là, justement,
pour lui faire passer un moment.
- Un club qui a envie d'accueillir
des personnes, tu vois,
qui a cet état d'esprit d'accueillir
des personnes en situation de handicap,
c’est-à-dire qu’en fait, il a l'état d'esprit
d'aider tout le monde.